Guten Morgen Thomas.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich sag dir, die Wüste ist auch nicht mehr das, was sie war. Es ist alles grün hier.
Ach, der Desert is a lie.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 490 vom 20. April 2024.
Und ja, es ist warm hier.
Warm und grün. Du bist in Abu Dhabi. Jaja, ich bin gerade in den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten,
und kann dir sagen, alles was du über die Wüste bisher gesagt bekommen hast,
stimmt einfach alles gar nicht. Es ist einfach ein großer Hoax.
Ich fahre hier in die Wüste, alles blüht, überall grün, Bäume.
Das finde ich völlig absurd. Und dann komme ich nach Dubai und dann ist dann
gleich Weltuntergangsstimmung wegen Regen.
Ah, sehr lustig. Ja, das war die größte jemals aufgezeichnete Regenmenge, die da runterkam.
Da kam irgendwie so eine Jahresladung Regen runter.
Und es war ganz putzig mit anzuschauen, wie die Stadt so mit Regen zu kämpfen hatte.
Also man hat schon gemerkt, dass sie bisher nicht so einen großen Wert darauf
gelegt haben, mal zu gucken, ob eigentlich auch alles wasserdicht ist.
Also mit anderen Worten, du läufst durch die Shopping Mall und alle stellen
überall Eimer hin und schieben Wasser zusammen und es tropft für dich überall rein.
Also ja, das war ganz lustig mit anzuschauen.
Schönes Naturereignis, oder?
Ja, Klimawandel kann auch unterhaltsam sein. Du weißt gar nicht, was du mal alle haben.
At first. Naja, so ist das halt.
Gut, Thomas, genau. Wir machen noch mal eine Sendung heute zusammen,
weil der Dinos noch verhindert ist.
Aber ich bin ganz optimistisch, dass es vielleicht nächste Woche dann schon
wieder so weit sein wird, dass er hier mitgestaltet.
Aber das gibt uns die Gelegenheit, über das Wetter zu reden und das ist ja auch
immer was Schönes. Wie ist das Wetter bei dir so gerade in Wien?
Es hat gerade fürchterlich gehagelt und ich habe schon auf Social Media gesehen,
dass in Linz gerade Überschwemmung ist.
Also ja, das Wetter, was du gerade hattest. Das ist auch nicht anders sozusagen.
Ja, ist klar. Gut, dann lass uns mal ein bisschen Feedback machen.
Ich hatte ja in der letzten Sendung die Freude mit Sabrina mal eine Sendung zu gestalten.
Sabrina ist Podcasterin, macht den Podcast Parlamentsrevue und fasst das Bundestagsgeschehen
sehr unterhaltsam zusammen.
Und damit sie das auch gut zusammenfassen kann, hat sie dann noch dazu diesen
Bundestagszusammenfasser programmiert, den du glaube ich noch nicht kanntest, ne?
Ne, noch nicht. Aber das Projekt schaut wirklich extrem interessant aus,
also so sollte Demokratie eigentlich sein.
Ja, also das fand ich auch und ein Grund mehr, das mal hier auch zu erwähnen.
Und zu unseren Ausführungen gab es dann aber auch noch ein paar Kommentare,
unter anderem von Privacy by Default.
In meinem Berufsleben habe ich viel mit der Verwaltung und ihrer schmerzhaften
Digitalisierung zu tun.
Deshalb habe ich das Bedürfnis, eine aus meiner Sicht wichtige Ursache für den
FUBA, den wir alle erleben, zu ergänzen, da sie im Podcast nicht direkt erwähnt
wurde. Der Föderalismus.
Abgesehen von lange Zeit fehlenden Standards, zum Beispiel für Schnittstellen
oder Datenformate, langsam ändert sich das übrigens, natürlich dürfen sich auf
diesem Gebiet auch die Aküfi und Akronymfreaks der Ministerien austoben.
Mein Lächerheitsliebling ist Zugpferd für die elektronische Rechnung,
ist echt jeder und seine Oma irgendwie am Mitmischen.
Während auf der einen Seite im Podcast wird es erwähnt, die Online-Zugangsgesetz-Novelle
im Bundesrat scheitert, weil die Länder es für unzumutbar halten,
gab es vorher dazu passendes Gemecker der Kommunalverbände, Städtetag,
Landkreistag, Gemeindetag, die sich ebenfalls beklagen.
In der Regel geht es da ums Geld, was ja auch nachvollziehbar ist.
Wenn man aber auf der anderen Seite, wie in der IT üblich und auch mit Erfolg
erprobt, versucht Standardisierung voranzubringen, pochen dieselben Akteure
auf ihre föderalistische Unabhängigkeit
und wollen sich vom Bund mal gar nichts vorschreiben lassen.
Dazu kommt dann noch das Problem, dass es in vielen Amtsstuben gar nicht so
einfach ist, die Fragen, was machen sie hier eigentlich, wozu und was brauchen
sie dafür oder was brauchen sie dafür nicht, vernünftig beantwortet zu bekommen.
Ohne diese Antworten ist das aber leider gar nicht so leicht Prozesse festzustellen,
diese möglichst effizient zu
digitalisieren und entsprechende Anforderungsbeschreibungen zu verfassen.
Ich empfehle jedem und jeder, die in der Wirtschaft zu Hause ist,
mal ein Praktikum in der öffentlichen Verwaltung.
Danach lernt ihr Alkohol echt zu schätzen.
Und PS, wenn es dann droht, so richtig gegen die Wand zu fahren,
ist gerne der Datenschutz schuld.
Wobei ich dann ins Spiel komme. Aber auch hier gilt, irgendwer muss es ja machen.
Genau, irgendwer muss es ja machen, ist ja auch die Tagline vom Bundestagszusammenfasser.
Das sind mir die liebsten Projekte. Irgendwer muss das machen.
Okay, gut, dann mache ich.
Also er spricht da wirklich ein paar Sachen an. Ich meine Föderalismus,
ich dachte wir hätten es tangiert, dass das ein Problem ist.
Aber klar, also auf der einen Seite, wir wollen uns nichts vorschreiben lassen,
aber auf der anderen Seite beklagen, dass man keine Hilfe bekommt.
Und dann auch dieses klassische IT-Problem, Digitalisierungsproblem,
das kenne ich auch nur noch sehr gut aus frühen Tagen schon,
dass du eben oft in so Organisationen, also in dem Fall waren es halt am Anfang
vor allem erstmal Firmen, die gerne alles irgendwie digitalisiert haben wollen, reinkommst.
Und dann musst du ja im Prinzip, meine, programmieren und digitalisieren heißt
ja im Prinzip Prozesse verstehen, Prozesse neu ordnen und dann eben versuchen, das digital zu fassen.
Aber wenn dann halt die Leute selber eigentlich gar nicht wissen,
was sie tun oder nicht in der Lage sind, es zu beschreiben, was sie tun,
weil sie es halt irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, nicht abstrakt abgespeichert haben, sondern halt einfach irgendwie machen,
aus dem Bauch heraus, was ja auch ganz nachvollziehbar ist, dann wird es natürlich
schwierig und dann wird es natürlich vor allem schwierig, wenn man den Staat
versucht zu digitalisieren.
Ja, dazu nur, weil ich das Wort Amtsstuben in dem Kommentar hier gelesen habe.
Wir verlinken irgendwo die wunderbare Satireserie MA2412 aus Österreich.
Österreich ist ja sehr stolz auf seinen Beamtenstaat und da kann man sehr gut lachen.
Also das hat wenig mit Digitalisierung zu tun, eher so früher 2000er,
aber da versteht man dann vielleicht auch das Verzweifeln, wenn man in diesem
Bereich tätig ist und das ist unterhaltsam.
Das ist sowas wie The Office für Österreich, ja?
The Office nur für die Verwaltung.
Okay, also hätte man es auch die Verwaltung nennen können.
MA24, habe ich noch nie gehört, aber werde ich mir mal anschauen. Bestimmt lustig.
Ich habe eigentlich gute Erfahrungen mit lustigen Sachen aus Österreich.
Die Sachen waren dann immer richtig lustig.
Lange lebe Kottan.
Ich muss dann aber auch noch den Zugpferd, ich meine, okay, gut,
das hatte ich übrigens in der letzten Freakshow mal ausführlich besprochen,
das Thema elektronische Rechnung und auch was es mit Zugpferd so auf sich hat.
Ich fand es eigentlich ganz lustig, muss ich sagen, dass sie sich so genannt haben.
Immerhin haben sie was Praktisches definiert, was offensichtlich auch ganz gut
funktionieren scheint.
Also nicht, dass ich das jetzt täglich in der Anwendung habe.
Im Prinzip ist das einfach das Hinzufügen von einer,
maschinenlesbaren Variante einer Rechnung zu einem PDF. Sehr praktische Geschichte.
Aber egal. Er hat schon recht, die Abkürzungen sind teilweise wirklich irre.
Das gilt wahrscheinlich auch für MA2412, oder?
Ja, das steht für Magistratsabteilung 2412. Aber ich frage mich eher nur so
bei Zugpferd, wir wollen ja europäische Standards haben.
Wie spricht man das denn aus in Ungarn oder in Frankreich?
Ja, also die gute Nachricht ist, Zugpferd ist quasi nur der Name eigentlich
letztendlich der Arbeitsgruppe, die sich zusammengefunden hat,
um dieses Problem mal zu lösen.
Und tatsächlich entspricht das aber auch einer europäischen Norm.
Auf international heißt das EN 16931.
Ist nicht so sexy wie Zugpferd.
Ja, es gibt dann natürlich noch ein paar andere sexy internationale Sachen,
das heißt dann, jetzt muss ich gleich nochmal kurz nachschauen,
das war Zugfahrt, die internationalen Standards sind dann die Cross-Industry Invoice CIE,
und in die Universal Business Language.
Ob das jetzt so sehr viel besser ist, weiß ich ja auch nicht.
Naja, auf Französisch heißt es übrigens Faktürex.
Und auf Deutschbehördisch heißt es X-Rechnung.
So stellen sich das Amerikaner, glaube ich, immer vor, wie Deutsche sowas nennen würden. X-Rechnung.
Die rufen dann gleich die Polizei.
Gut, haben wir noch Kommentare? Ja, wir haben noch weitere Kommentare.
Wo war ich?
Komme ich schon ganz ab von der Spur. Genau, wir haben noch Hypercrafter,
der auch noch was zum Thema Digitalisierung sagt.
Zum Thema Digitalisierung und Bürokratie, Vereinfachung von Gemeinden.
In Bayern gibt es die AKDB, Anstalt für kommunale Datenverarbeitung in Bayern.
Diese entwickeln Programme für Gemeinden, die sogenannte OK-Reihe.
Des Weiteren ist die AKDB-Initiatorin der BAIKIT, die bayernweit Ausschreibungen
durchführen für die Gemeinden.
Und sie haben eine Tochter namens
Living Data, die Hardware beschafft und Störungen und Probleme behebt.
Also so fremd es auch klingt, aber Bayern liegt in der Digitalisierung der Gemeinden
weiter vorne als manch anderes Bundesland.
Disclaimer, Quelle, ich bin Auszubildender bei Living Data. Okay,
gut, nehmen wir so hin. Und dann haben wir noch was von STQ.
Ja, sie schreibt, ist es tatsächlich so, dass in Deutschland jedes Ministerium
und jedes Bundesland seine eigenen Gesetze verwaltet?
Da muss man ja erstmal wissen, aus welchem Ressort ein Gesetz stammt.
Ich will ja nicht ätzen, aber in Österreich gibt es das Rechtsinformationssystem
des Bundes, in dem praktische sämtliche Gesetze und Verordnungen sowohl auf
Bundes- als auch Landesebene vorliegen.
Und zwar immer in der geltenden Fassung, als auch historisch.
Seit Juli letzten Jahres gibt es sogar viele Gemeindegesetze dort auffindbar.
Und auf der Parlamentsseite hat man konsolidiert alle Eingaben,
Gesetzesvorlagen, Stellungnahmen und Beschlüsse.
Inwieweit es allerdings auch eine API für die beiden Seiten gibt,
ist leider nicht bekannt. Ist dir das vielleicht bekannt?
Ja, also das RISS, wie wir es ganz liebevoll nennen, das Rechtsinformationssystem,
ist eigentlich eine wirklich schöne Sache.
Das haben sich die Leute Anfang der 2000er einfallen lassen.
So was machen wir denn jetzt eigentlich mit diesem Internet und mit den Gesetzen?
Lasst uns das alles einfach als CC0, also wirklich komplett frei lizenziert,
offen ins Netz hauen mit API, weil das gehört ja uns allen und was soll man sonst damit machen?
War eine sehr kluge Entscheidung und das RISS wird verwendet für alle Bundes-,
Landes- und eben auch jetzt auch Gemeindegesetze.
Es ist auch versehen mit den Gerichtsentscheidungen, die veröffentlicht werden,
wobei da natürlich nicht alle an die Öffentlichkeit kommen, weil da muss man
manchmal anonymisieren.
Aber man kann da unheimlich gut nachschlagen. Man findet dort alles und auch
wirklich revisioniert alle vorherigen Fassungen von Gesetzen.
Und man findet dort auch aktive und vergangene Begutachtungsverfahren.
Also wenn Gesetze konsolidiert werden.
Was da aber fehlt, ist das, was im Parlament passiert.
Also Änderungsanträge, die in Ausschüssen eingebracht werden,
Parlamentsreden und so.
Der Gesetzwerdungsprozess, der ist da leider nicht drinnen.
Wir haben eine Parlamentswebseite, die wurde auch mit der kürzlichen Renovierung
des Parlaments neu gemacht, aber die ist wirklich ein, also ich habe da physische
Schmerzen, wenn ich drauf schauen muss.
Und natürlich gibt es keine API, es gab mal das Projekt Offenes Parlament,
das da mit Scrapern versucht hat, mit der Brechstange Transparenz reinzubekommen,
die haben aber aufgegeben, weil man es ihnen auch wirklich so schwierig gemacht hat.
Also da ist der, wie heißt der, Parlamentszusammenfasser von euch,
Bundestagszusammenfasser, da schaue ich neidisch drauf, weil halt gerade eben
diese Gesetzwerdung, die Etappen, die ein Gesetz nehmen muss,
was sagen denn die einzelnen Parteien dazu, von wem kommt welcher Änderungsantrag?
Die Transparenz fehlt uns in Österreich, wir haben wirklich nur die beschlossenen
Sachen und die eingebrachten Sachen und die Gerichtsentscheidungen wirklich als offene Daten.
Mhm.
Immerhin. Also deutsche Gesetze sind auch im Internet.
Ich weiß bloß jetzt nicht, wie vollständig. Wir hatten es auch kurz angesprochen,
aber ich habe es jetzt gerade nicht mehr so ganz im Kopf. Naja, gut.
Also nach wie vor, wer Lust hat, beim Bundestagszusammenfasser ein bisschen noch mitzuhelfen.
Sabrina freut sich über jede Hilfe und ja, keine Ahnung, wenn davon irgendwas
verwendbar ist für Österreich, glaube ich, ist sie da auch durchaus ansprechbar.
Seit der letzten Sendung hat sich auch schon was getan.
Mittlerweile sind auch alle Termine der Ausschüsse mit dabei.
Das heißt, man sieht sowohl auf der Homepage als auch auf den einzelnen Gesetzesseiten
nicht nur in welchem Zustand befindet sich sozusagen gerade alles,
also innerhalb des Gesetzesprozesses,
sondern man kriegt auch schön detailliert die Termine in den Ausschüssen aufgelistet,
wo da demnächst wieder drüber geredet wird.
Also das ist in der Tat ein immer besseres Tool, um sich da zu engagieren.
Ich blicke neidisch darauf, vielleicht wird das so wie Frag den Staat,
was ja auch in Deutschland gestartet ist und jetzt auch in Österreich sehr erfolgreich ist.
Also da würde mich Open Source Reuse wirklich freuen.
Aber bleiben wir bei den lustigen Österreich-Sachen. Wir haben einen schönen Kommentar bekommen.
Ich habe in der letzten Sendung so einen Wortwitz gemacht.
Ich glaube, das war im Kontext von dieser abgehörten Konversation von deutschen
Militärleuten, wo auch jemand einen gewissen akademischen Titel hatte.
Ich weiß nicht mal welchen.
Und ich meinte so irgendwie, ja, der hat diesen Titel scheinbar bei Humboldt gemacht.
Und darauf fragte Stefan D., was hat es eigentlich mit diesem Humboldt-Aufsicht?
Ich habe das schon öfters gehört, das scheint irgendein Insiderwitz in Österreich zu sein.
Und darauf antwortet Alex, ja, das war ein Anbieter von Fernkunsten in Österreich,
meistens berufsbegleitend. Eine Humboldt-Ausbildung hatte den Ruf,
eher drittklassig zu sein. Ob zu Recht, kann ich nicht sagen.
Anfang der 2000er gab es da auch mal eine lustige Werbekampagne und ja,
ich kann da auf jeden Fall aufklären, genau das ist, worauf ich mich auch bezogen habe.
Mir war nicht bewusst, dass dieser Witz in Deutschland nicht verstanden wird.
Ist halt so klassisches Fernstudium so Tele-Uni.
Antwort war von Axel, nicht Alex genau, ah danke okay gut, also so Doktor aufwisch
bestellt dann oder was genau.
Und dann ebenso eine interessante sprachliche Klarstellung kam von wiederum Axel,
der meinte, unter Umständen bin ich etwas spät dran damit, aber ich habe die
Woche zum ersten Mal Entgendern nach Fettberg,
YouTube-Video verlinkt, gehört.
So gesehen kann es sein, dass Thomas bei 1 Stunde 13 und 49 Sekunden Aktivisti sagt.
Und da hat Axel recht. Ich habe das Wort verwendet als genderneutrale Form von
Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten. Und mir war aber gar nicht bewusst,
dass ich damit nach Fettberg gendere.
Fettberg war ein sehr bekannter Kabarettist aus Österreich, der in seinem Körperumfang,
seinem Namen wirklich alle Ehre gemacht hat.
Und insofern, wir verlieren auch da nochmal auf den Kommentar und das Video.
Das ist durchaus lustig. Und zuletzt noch eine sehr hilfreiche Klarstellung
von Theresa Akt zum Thema der fortwährenden Zuständigkeit des Europäischen Gerichtshofs
für Menschenrechte für Altfälle.
Sechs Monate nach ihrem Ausschluss aus dem Europarat ist die russische Föderation ab dem 16.
September 2022 keine Vertragspartei der Europäischen Menschenrechtskonvention mehr.
Das haben wir, glaube ich, in der Sendung erwähnt. Aber jetzt kommt die interessante Klarstellung.
Der Europäische Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte ist weiterhin für die Bearbeitung
von Handlungen oder Unterlassungen betreffenden Beschwerden gegen Russland zuständig, die bis zum 16.
September 2022 eingereicht wurden. Vor dem Gerichtshof sind derzeit 17.450 Beschwerden
gegen Russland anhängig.
Gemäß der Europäischen Menschenrechtskonvention ist Russland rechtlich verpflichtet,
Urteile und Entscheidungen des Gerichtshofs umzusetzen.
Das Ministerkomitee des Europarates wird weiterhin die Umsetzung der betreffenden
Urteile und gültigen Entscheidungen überwachen.
2.219 Urteile und Entscheidungen müssen von Russland noch vollständig umgesetzt
werden und sind noch beim Ministerkomitee anhängig.
Da gibt es auch schöne Statistiken zu anderen Ländern,
das ist an sich nämlich ein gar nicht so unterschätzendes Problem,
dass auch so diese EGMR-Urteile von manchen Ländern einfach ignoriert werden
und das sind nicht nur Staaten, die man da vielleicht irgendwie so klassifizieren
würde wie Russland oder Ungarn, sondern auch wirklich zentraleuropäische Staaten.
Also ist an sich ein Problem für die Rechtsstaatlichkeit.
Alright, soviel zum Feedback. Dann können wir ja mal hier in unsere Themen einsteigen.
Und wie sollte es anders sein?
Wir gehen zunächst einmal nach Österreich. Da gibt es was Lustiges,
Unterhaltsames, hast du mir versprochen.
Ja, ich versuche jetzt den Wahnsinn logisch und stringent zusammenzufassen und
ich hoffe, dass ich nicht zu groß scheitern werde.
Also, was ist passiert?
Österreich befindet sich gerade im größten Spionageskandal seiner Geschichte.
Es sind Daten nach Russland abgeflossen und wurden Institutionen der österreichischen
Sicherheitsarchitektur unterwandert, wie wir das eigentlich so noch nie hatten
in der Zweiten Republik.
Und dieser größte Spionageskandal beginnt, wo soll ich anfangen, mit einer Einer Person,
einem Kärntner Polizisten genannt, Egis Duot, der war beim Verfassungsschutz,
dem Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und Terrorismusbekämpfung,
auch kurz BVT genannt, viele Jahre tätig und wurde dort aber 2017 suspendiert,
weil ein befreundeter Dienst,
ich glaube es waren die Briten, gemeldet haben, der hat gerade irgendwie dienstliche
Informationen auf einen Gmail-Account sich geschickt.
Also ist er beim Verfassungsschutz oder ist er Polizist? Also ist man nicht entweder oder?
In Österreich leider nicht. In Österreich ist es so, dass wir kein Trennungsgebot
zwischen Polizei und Nachrichtendienst haben.
Das ist auch weiterhin ein Problem, was wir immer wieder kritisieren,
aber es gibt da eine Behörde mit beiden Rollen und teils sind es unterschiedliche
Personen, die sich für unterschiedliche Sachen kümmern.
Aber so eine Firebowl dazwischen, wie man das in der Schweiz oder Deutschland
kennt, gibt es leider nicht.
In Deutschland läuft das ja
unter Lehren aus der Nazi-Zeit, aber damit hattet ihr hier nichts zu tun.
Ja, da haben wir nicht viel gelernt.
Okay, also. Gisto Ott.
Ägisto Ott, schöner Name und Ägisto Ott ist angeblich, also der wurde 2017 eben
dann suspendiert, weil er eben Informationen, die nur für den Dienstgebrauch waren,
auf sein privates Gmail geschickt hat und wir wissen ja alle,
die Five Eyes haben ein Auge oder mehrere auf Gmail.
Also mindestens fünf würde ich sagen. Ja.
Und es ist ihnen nicht entgangen, dass da geheimdienstliche Informationen wohin
gingen, wo sie nicht hätten hingehen sollen.
Und daraufhin wurde Ott suspendiert.
Das hat ihn aber nicht davon abgehalten, weiterhin tätig zu sein.
Und er war tätig, indem er zum Beispiel Informationen abgefragt hat aus dem
Akten, dem elektronischen Aktensystem der Sicherheitsdienste in Österreich.
Er hat sich weiterhin mit seinem Dienstausweis bei ausländischen Partnerdiensten
vorstellig geworden und hat dort Informationen abgesammelt, zum Beispiel aus Italien.
Er ist zu Bezirksämtern gegangen und hat sich dort Meldeadressen ausheben lassen.
Unter anderem von einem der Journalisten, der, ich glaube, er hat für Bellingcat
gearbeitet und war auch die Person, die mit Alexej Nawalny, nachdem der den
Novichok-Anschlag überlebt hat, ja aufgeklärt hat, wer waren die russischen Hintermänner.
Du erinnerst dich wahrscheinlich an diesen legendären Telefonanruf, wo Nawalny die Leute,
die ihn versucht haben umzubringen, angerufen hat und sich als russischer Offizieller
ausgegeben hat und die niedergemacht hat und sich genau erklären hat lassen, wie das passiert ist.
Da war dieser Journalist daran beteiligt.
Und jetzt kommt es, der hat das alles auch im Auftrag von Russland getan.
Gisto Ott hat Sina-Laptops. Sina-Laptops sind von Deutschen besonders gehärtete,
gesicherte Laptops, die für geheime und streng geheime Materialien zugelassen sind.
Die dürften über ihn gechannelt nach Russland gegangen sein.
Und natürlich massiver vertrauensbruch ja also am geräte selber vollständig,
Die ist komplett verschwunden.
So einfach.
Ja, und da gibt es dann auch Teile dieser Informationslieferungen,
da weiß man dann, okay, die Person, die da Kurier gespielt hat,
von Österreich raus, mit dem Flieger nach Moskau, ins Hotel neben der FSB-Zentrale eingecheckt.
Also wir wissen auch sehr viele dieser Dinge, weil Jan Marsalek,
ein anderer Österreicher, den man vielleicht noch kennt aus der Wirecard-Affäre,
wo er ja das angebliche Mastermind dieses Milliardenbetruges war,
wo wir auch immer mehr herausfinden, wie Wirecard für die Finanzierung von russischen
Aktivitäten in Europa herangezogen wurde.
Und Jan Marsalek hatte einen Spionagering von bulgarischen StaatsbürgerInnen,
einem Trio, das vor kurzem in Großbritannien festgenommen wurde,
dem gerade dadurch der Prozess gemacht wird.
Und in deren Telefonen findet sich ganz viel Kommunikation zwischen Jan Marsalek
und eben seiner Geheimdienstzelle, die er geführt hat, vornehmlich im Auftrag von Russland.
Und im Zuge dieser, wir wissen ja, Jan Maaselek als Wirecard dann implodierte
und dieser Milliardenbetrug auffiel, ist Maaselek ja die Flucht gelungen,
zuerst nach Belarus und dann nach Russland.
Bei dieser Flucht geholfen hat ihm ein anderer Beamter des Verfassungsschutzes
in Österreich genannt, Martin Weiß.
Aus diesen Chats wissen wir auch, Martin Weiß, der dann auch ins Fadenkreuz
der Ermittlungen kam, ja der ist inzwischen da, wo du gerade bist, in Dubai. bei.
Und Marselek hat in den Chats auch gesagt, ja, den Weiß, den haben wir jetzt, Zitat, evakuiert.
Also der wird wahrscheinlich nicht mehr zurückkommen, um sich der Strafverfolgung zu stellen.
Martin Weiß war der Vorgesetzte von Egistoort. Egistoort ist weiter in Österreich,
der ist auch seit kurzem in Haft.
Da wird jetzt auch gerade massiv versucht aufzuklären, was denn eigentlich ja
wirklich alles passiert ist.
Und es gibt noch ein.
Das könnte nicht österreichischer sein, diese Geschichte. Ein Detail, das muss ich erzählen.
Es gibt auch noch drei Telefone, die es nach Russland geschafft haben.
Und da war es so, ich glaube es war 2016,
wir hatten Innenminister Sobotka, kein besonders charmanter Mensch und dieser
Innenminister hat zu einem Firmenfest in einem Ministerium so ein Teambuilding-Event dahingeladen.
Und da sind die Leute dann irgendwie, haben wahrscheinlich getrunken,
gegessen und sind dann auch mit Kanus durch einen See gefahren.
Und die Frau von unserem aktuellen Bundeskanzler, Karl Nehammer,
war auch bei diesem Ausflug dabei, war auch in einem dieser Kanus dabei,
nur wusste nicht, dass man halt in Kanus nicht aufstehen sollte,
weil sonst kentern die Dinger.
Ja, kein Vorkommen. Hat sie aber gemacht.
Genau. Und drei hochrangige Kabinettsmitarbeiter waren mit ihr in diesem Kanu
und deren Telefone wurden nass in dem See.
Was macht man da? Da waren ja wichtige Daten drauf. Man bringt sie zu der IT-Abteilung
des Verfassungsschutzes, so bitte repariert die Dinger oder rettet die Daten zumindest.
Was macht der IT-Dienstleister dort?
Er gibt sie mal in Reis rein, so du kennst diese Urban Myth.
Nasse Telefone, Schale mit Reis, zumachen, beten, vielleicht wird es besser.
Viel retten konnte er dann nicht, aber dann hat sich auch irgendwie keiner mehr
gekümmert um diese drei Telefone.
Die lagen da vornehmlich, laut Medienberichten, sehr lange im Spind herum. Warum?
Das kann man noch irgendwie so rekonstruieren. Und dann später hat Egisto Ott
gemeint, er hat sie in einem Briefumschlag in seinem Postfach gehabt.
Die sind einfach da so magisch zu ihm gekommen. Aufgetaucht.
Ja, und wie gesagt, sie haben es dann auch geschafft, nach Moskau zu kommen.
Also die sind inzwischen auch, nach dem, was wir aus den Chats wissen,
eben im russischen Einflussbereich, was natürlich auch nochmal ein massiver
Vertrauensverlust und Datenabfluss aus dem Ministerium, was für Spionageabwehr
und für die innere Sicherheit Österreichs zuständig ist.
Bedeutet.
Und letzter Punkt, so ist es dort, angeblich laut einer Analyse,
wie nennt man das denn, wenn man so Schrifttypen vergleicht,
wie Leute schreiben, ist er auch der Verfasser eines sehr berühmt gewordenen Pamphlets,
in dem der österreichische Verfassungsschutz mit sehr harten Vorwürfen konfrontiert
wird, unter anderem Pässe an Nordkorea verkauft zu haben und so weiter.
Dieses Pamphlet zirkulierte schon einige Monate.
Keiner hat es wirklich ernst genommen. Weder die Staatsanwaltschaft,
noch die Journalistinnen und Journalisten, die das bekommen haben.
Aber das Pamphlet war handgeschrieben.
Nein, das war virtuell, das waren irgendwie mehrere Dokumente, aber auf jeden Fall.
Also nicht die Handschrift, sondern die Schreibart sozusagen,
die Wortwahl, die wurde analysiert, okay.
Da gibt es sicherlich jetzt in den Kommentaren werden wir lesen,
wie das heißt. Ich glaube, da gibt es auch zumindest Gutachten, die man bekommen kann.
Ich kann nichts dazu sagen, wie aussagekräftig die sind. Auf jeden Fall wurde
da Ott, der ja, wie wir vorher gehört haben, suspendiert wurde,
der nichts mehr wurde innerhalb dieses sehr mächtigen Apparates,
hat dem Vernehmer nach hier seinen Unmut über Postenschacher und Korruption zum Ausdruck gebracht.
Und bei dem Postenschacher glaube ich ihm auch.
Und diese Vorwürfe, dass da die konservative ÖVP den Verfassungsschutz dafür
missbraucht, ihre Leute unterzubringen und Versorgungsposten zu schaffen,
war so einer der Vorwürfe.
Und als wir dann einen blauen Innenminister hatten mit Herbert Kickl von der
FPÖ, der rechtsextremen Partei in Österreich,
wurde diesem Pamphlet aber auf einmal sehr viel Glauben gegeben und es war dann
auch die Basis für eine Hausdurchsuchung im Verfassungsschutz.
Eine Hausdurchsuchung im Verfassungsschutz, die nur aufgrund dieser komischen
Vorwürfe, die vorher niemanden interessiert haben,
hat dazu geführt, dass man halt wirklich in das Innerste des Verfassungsschutzes
vorgedrungen ist, auch alle nachrichtendienstlichen Informationen damit dort komprimiert waren.
Und der Verfassungsschutz ist in Österreich wie auch in Deutschland natürlich
auch für die Beobachtung der rechtsextremen Szene verantwortlich.
Und lustigerweise war mit dieser Hausdurchsuchung ein Politiker der FPÖ betraut,
der nämlich Leiter einer Polizeieinheit für Straßenkriminalität ist.
Die haben nichts mit Korruption zu tun, aber die waren lustigerweise diejenigen,
die dann dort einmarschiert sind.
Und lustigerweise hat man auch das Büro der Referatsleiterin,
die sich mit eben jenen Rechtsextremen im Verfassungsschutz beschäftigt und
diese beobachtet, da besonders dafür interessiert.
Und wie wir heute wissen, weil es da auch gerade einen Untersuchungsausschuss
gibt, wieder einmal, das ist schon der zweite in dieser Causa,
die hatte wirklich so, das ist wieder sehr österreichisch, auf ihrem Schreibtisch noch.
Ausgedruckt die Einladung von Herrn Küssl, das ist ein sehr berühmter Rechtsextremer,
der schon wirklich wegen Wiederbetätigung verurteilt ist in Österreich.
Der hat eben jene Person zu einem Treffen eingeladen, die die Hausdurchsuchung geleitet hat.
Und dieser Zettel war lustigerweise nachher weg von dem Schreibtisch.
Und er war aber nicht bei den Dokumenten, die sichergestellt wurden.
Und wir wissen auch, dass das Innenministerium von all dem, was es nachher wissen
wollte, über die Haustischsuchung, vor allem eben diese Infos aus diesem Büro,
wo Rechtsextremistinnen eben beobachtet wurden.
Das hat sie interessiert. Also es könnte nicht perfider sein und es ist pure
Operette, aber leider ist es die Realität.
Und vielleicht gibt es deswegen so viele lustige Sachen aus Österreich,
weil man nur noch lachen kann, wenn man nicht weinen will.
Und das ist so gerade, was abgeht im Land. Und jetzt kommt aber die netzpolitische Tangente.
Und das Learning, die Forderung, die jetzt massiv erhoben wird, schon seit zwei Wochen,
ich glaube, wir haben in unserem Verein sogar 20 Interviews gegeben in den letzten
zwei Wochen, ist, dass man jetzt als Reaktion auf diesen massiven Spionageskandal,
jetzt braucht man einen Staatstrojaner.
Jetzt braucht man unbedingt einen Bundestrojaner.
Das hätte es ja sicherlich verhindert.
Ja, also diese Chats, die sind so gefährlich, wir müssen da jetzt ran.
Und die Briten konnten da Handys überwachen und wir wollen die auch überwachen.
Dass das gar nicht der Fall ist, weil das waren ja Leute, die waren vor Gericht.
Natürlich war das Handy sichergestellt und wurde forensisch ausgewertet und
physisch hinzugefasst.
Das können die Österreicher heute auch schon.
Die Spionagesoftware können sie nicht. Die haben wir ihnen schon dreimal vereitelt.
2016, 2017, 2019 zuletzt beim Verfassungsgerichtshof.
Es gab schon drei Gesetze, die gescheitert sind, um Staatstrojaner in Österreich zu legalisieren.
Aber jetzt ist die massive Forderung des Innenministeriums,
des Verfassungsschutzes, aller Polizistinnen, die in den Medien sprechen und
auch leider der Kontrollkommission für die Geheimdienste, ja wir brauchen jetzt einen Bundestrojaner.
Also der Missbrauch von Kompetenzen wird mit der Ausweitung von Kompetenzen belohnt.
Und das ist zum Glück für die Grünen, den Koalitionspartner in Österreich,
die rote Linie, die nicht überschritten werden darf.
Aber diese Debatte ist gerade massiv und wir hoffen, dass wir da die Linie halten können.
Das ist gerade wieder so Thema und es ist auch sehr nah an der deutschen Debatte.
In Deutschland gibt es Quellen-TKÜ und Online-Durchsuchung. Also diese Spionagesoftware,
leitet die nur das aus, was kommuniziert wird von dem Telefon?
Oder schaut die sich auch an, was auf dem Gerät für Bilder, Adresseinträge,
Entwürfe von Nachrichten, die vielleicht nie abgesendet wurden,
was da sonst eben noch gespeichert ist.
Und diese technische Funktion, die meiner Meinung nach, also diese rechtliche
Funktion, die technisch gar nicht funktioniert, wird da auch gerade wieder ins Spiel gebracht.
Also ja, das ist so grob die Debatte.
Immer Dreck am Stecken haben und ihr Geschäftsmodell sie dazu bringt,
dass sie mit sehr zweifelhaften Akteuren ins Geschäft kommen und denen auch
diese massiven Spionagetools in die Hand geben.
In Polen hat die neue Regierung gerade, glaube ich, es waren 600 Fälle aufgedeckt,
wo Pegasus in Polen eingesetzt wurde.
Also das ist einfach eine Gefahntechnologie, die es zu ächten gilt.
Und man sollte mit Steuergeld keine Sicherheitslücken finanzieren.
Ja, das war so irgendwie die Zusammenfassung und wir verlinken einen sehr tollen
Podcast zu dieser Sache.
Wir verlinken auch ein Comic, weil man muss alle Wege nutzen,
um das irgendwie verständlich zu machen.
Und natürlich so die ganzen Hintergründe zu dem, was da in Österreich los ist
und auch der Anzeige, die wir gegen diese Wiener Spionagefirma DSIRF eingebracht haben.
Aber dieser Polizist, dieser Herr Ott, der befindet sich jetzt in Gewahrsam oder was ist mit dem?
Der ist in Gewahrsam, der ist in Untersuchungshaft und wartet darauf,
dass ihm der Prozess gemacht wird.
Also der wird jetzt wirklich angezeigt wegen einer Spionagetätigkeit.
Das ist auch wieder so ein Kuriosum. In Österreich ist Spionage...
Nicht verboten.
In jedem anderen Land der Welt ist es so, hey, du machst hier nachrichtendienstliche
Arbeit, geh ins Gefängnis und wenn du Diplomat bist, wirst du sofort ausgewiesen.
In Österreich sagt das Strafgesetzbuch, also ein ausländischer Nachrichtendienst
auf dem Boden Österreichs ist illegal, wenn er gegen die Interessen der Republik verstößt.
Und wir haben als einziges Land diesen Nachsatz, dass, also wenn du nichts gegen
uns machst, dann ist es ja okay, machst du ruhig.
Und das ist mit ein Grund, wieso Österreich so viele Botschaftsangestellte hat,
wieso wir die UNO, die OPEC, die OECD und andere internationale Organisationen
vor Ort haben, weil bei uns halt Spionagespielplatz ist.
Also ihr könnt schon gerne spionieren, aber jetzt nicht gegen uns.
Aber wenn es Russen sind, dann vielleicht doch.
Ja.
Also natürlich jetzt, wo diese sehr ungesunde Nähe Österreichs zu Russland endlich
Thema wird, je noch viel zu wenig im Vergleich zu Deutschland.
Also auch da sind wir hinten nach bei der Aufarbeitung unserer historisch falschen
Entscheidungen, um es freundlich zu formulieren.
Da gehört natürlich auch das dazu. Und es gibt jetzt halt eben auch die Forderung,
okay, kriminalisieren wir denn wirklich mal alle nachrichtendienstliche Aktivität?
Und nicht nur die, die sich gegen Österreich wendet.
Würde ja auch vielleicht den internationalen Organisationen in Österreich helfen,
wenn die wissen, dass sie nicht ganz so unter Beobachtung stehen.
Aber wie gesagt, da will die konservative Koalitionspartei, die ÖVP,
den Bundestrojaner im Abtausch haben dafür. für ansonsten ist ihnen die ausländische
Spionage scheinbar egal.
Ich meine, ich glaube, was man verstehen muss, wenn man es nicht weiß,
ist ja, Österreich hat es ja mit seinem...
Wie soll ich sagen, mit dieser Chimäre der Neutralität, ist ja tatsächlich geschafft,
sich international zu einem der Konferenzstandorte zu machen.
Also meines Wissens ist Wien überhaupt sozusagen die Konferenzstadt Nummer eins
in Europa, also wo am meisten Konferenzen stattfinden.
Und es gibt natürlich eine extrem hohe Präsenz, nicht nur jetzt von Botschaften,
sondern eben von internationalen Organisationen. Wir haben das ja jetzt auch
mit der UN, mit der Aushandlung hier, an denen ihr gerade teilnehmt.
Und zahlreiche andere internationale Institute sind ja dort auch mit festen
Büros vertreten, aber es gibt halt generell auch sehr viel Konferenzpräsenz.
Und irgendwie liest sich das für mich so ein bisschen mit, naja,
wenn da so viel Konferenzaktivität ist, dann sind halt auch viele Spione da
und wenn wir jetzt anfangen, gegen die irgendwie vorzugehen und so,
dann finden ja keine Konferenzen mehr statt.
Das mag sogar mit einem Grund sein, dass ich, wenn du die Verhandlungen in Wien
machst, dann weißt du genau, worauf du dich einlässt, ja, das ist sozusagen,
da gibt es keine Überraschungen.
Ja, also wir wissen ja auch aus den Snowden-Folien, dass Österreich oder zumindest
Wien eine Full-Tech-Stadt ist,
also dass hier einfach alles aufgezeichnet wird und nachher ausgewertet,
weil also diese zwei Millionen Leute, die sich da herumgrundeln,
bevor wir jetzt die Diplomaten vorher rausfischen,
nehmen wir mal alles und schauen dann im Nachhinein, was wir brauchen.
Da haben wir dann vielleicht auch noch die Liebschaft oder die Drogendealer
von den Diplomaten auch noch mitgefangen. Könnte ja hilfreich sein.
Natürlich, aber das greift auch in das Grundrecht auf Datenschutz von allen
anderen Menschen hier in diesem Land ein.
Wir haben halt so überhaupt nicht reflektiert, was denn auch die Neutralität betrifft.
In dieser neuen Zeit nach dem Angriffskrieg Russlands auf die Ukraine denn bedeutet.
Und ich glaube, dass da Schweden und Finnland die klügeren Lehren draus gezogen haben.
Ich bin zwar überhaupt kein Fan von Militär und Militärausgaben,
aber man sollte halt entweder sagen, wir demilitarisieren komplett und sagen einfach so,
Inschallah hoffen wir, dass nichts passiert oder wir sind Teil der NATO und lassen uns schützen.
Also diese Debatte gibt es gerade halt auch.
Und ja, es gibt den BVT, von dem ich vorher gesprochen habe, auch nicht mehr.
Nach diesem massiven Vertrauensverlust, auch durch die Haustischsuchung und
die sonstigen Spompernadeln von Innenminister Kickl der FPÖ,
ist Österreich auch aus der Berner Gruppe ausgeschlossen worden.
Das ist ein Zusammenschluss westlicher Nachrichtendienste und das hat dann dazu
geführt, dass nach dem Terrorangreif in Wien vom November 2020 man das BVT abgeschafft hat,
eigentlich ein Grund zur Freude ist, einen Nachrichtendienst abzuschaffen.
Leider wurde genau danach halt der Nachfolger geschaffen.
Das ist die Direktion für Staatsschutz und Nachrichtendienst,
genannt DSN, die jetzt eben gerade zuständig ist für diese Dinge.
Berner Gruppe, also was ist das genau für eine, also wo kommt der Begriff her?
Ja, ich habe immer gedacht, dass das irgendwas mit der Schweiz zu tun hat,
aber also nachdem das irgendwie so Nachrichtendienste sind, glaube ich,
dass es da nicht so viel gibt.
Aber es ist, soweit das Medial immer berichtet wurde, ein Zusammenschluss westlicher
Nachrichtendienste, wo auch Informationen und Lagerbilder ausgetauscht werden.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die auch so ein bisschen Qualitätssicherung betreiben und
über was man sich dort insgesamt austauscht, aber die Idee ist,
neben den fünf Augen, den Five Eyes der Amis und der Briten,
eben nochmal eine zweite Gruppe zu haben,
die mehr Staaten beinhaltet und wahrscheinlich anhand von gemeinsamen geopolitischen
Interessen da eben versucht,
die Kooperation im nachrichtendienstlichen Bereich zu verbessern.
Ich habe es jetzt gerade unter dem Begriff Berner Club gefunden.
Das scheint wohl jetzt der gängige Begriff zu sein.
Auch Club de Bern oder Club de Berna.
Ah, der Z, ja.
Weil das der Sitz der CIA in Europa war.
Ah, okay, das macht Sinn.
Genau, Berner Club, okay, wieder was gelernt.
Österreich ist nicht eingeladen bei der Party, wie drauf.
Ja, und was ist jetzt, das habe ich nicht verstanden, mit NATO und Österreich?
Naja, Österreich ist ja nicht Teil der NATO und auch da eben als neutrales Land
haben wir immer gesagt, sagt, na,
wir wollen uns da blockfrei zwischen Ost und West positionieren,
was ja auch früher geografisch irgendwie noch Sinn gemacht hat.
Und anders als die Schweiz haben wir Neutralität aber nicht so verstanden,
dass wir weiter ein wehrhaftes Militär haben.
Das wird von vielen so als Voraussetzung gesehen dafür, dass man Neutralität
wirklich leben kann und auch dafür einstehen kann.
Und zwei andere neutrale Länder sind ja gerade der NATO beigetreten, Finnland und Schweden.
Und das hat auch so ein bisschen die Diskussion in Österreich ausgelöst.
Sind wir da Freerider? Also profitieren wir einfach nur davon,
dass wir umgeben sind von NATO-Ländern und der Schweiz? und kümmern uns deswegen
nicht um eine aktive Außen- und Verteidigungspolitik.
Sind wir überhaupt noch neutral bei gewissen Dingen? Also jetzt gerade eben
Ukraine-Russland und auch Nahostkonflikt haben wir eigentlich sehr klare Haltungen.
Und diese Debatte, die wird halt gerade geführt, aber noch gibt es da auch keine klare Richtung.
Die Neutralität ist ein bisschen so eine heilige Kuh in Österreich.
Die will keiner angreifen. Das ist genauso wie Atomkraft.
Diese Debatte haben wir beendet. Da wissen wir, wo wir stehen.
Und wenn du darüber sprichst, verlierst du nur Stimmen als politische Partei.
Das ist leider, wie das im Moment gelagert ist.
Okay, dann können wir glaube ich das Kapitel erstmal zumachen,
oder? Haben wir alles erstmal berichtet, ne?
Genug Österreich.
Genug Spionage-Kram.
So, kommen wir zur EIDAS Wallet.
Da haben wir ja auch vor ein paar Sendungen drüber gesprochen.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie lange ist das jetzt her?
Gute Frage. Wir haben wahrscheinlich darüber geredet, als das Gesetz verabschiedet
wurde, das EU-Gesetz zur digitalen Identität und zu dieser europäischen digitalen Identität Wallet.
Raus aus dem Bootstable, das war die Sendung, die du mit Linus zusammen gemacht
hast, Logbuch Netzpolitik 485, genau, IDAS und DPI.
Genau. Und jetzt ist das Gesetz in trockenen Tüchern und es stellt sich die
Frage, wie kommt man denn zu der Software, die das Ganze umsetzen soll und dem
ganzen Ökosystem, das ja da aufgezogen werden soll.
Und mit dieser Frage hat sich die deutsche Bundesregierung in den letzten Monaten
sehr intensiv beschäftigt und hatte da auch einen Konsultationsprozess.
Der anfangs sehr offen war. Ich war da gemeinsam mit vielen anderen NGOs am Anfang dabei.
Wirklich übrig geblieben sind dann eigentlich, glaube ich, nur zwei VertreterInnen
der Zivilgesellschaft,
die da wirklich durchgängig dabei waren, die eine unheimlich gute Arbeit gemacht
haben, um da diesen Architekturvorschlag, den die deutsche Bundesregierung jetzt
vorgelegt hat, zu verbessern.
Die zwei waren da wirklich alleine auf weiter Flur, weil ansonsten hatte keiner
den Atem, sich diesem Marathon an Meetings zu unterwerfen, außer der Industrie
natürlich, die war da sehr glücklich, ihre Vorstellungen einzubringen.
Wir haben jetzt auf jeden Fall mal diesen Architekturvorschlag,
den wir auch verlinken, das ist ein sehr langes Dokument und vor allem das Datenschutzkapitel
habe ich mir angesehen und da muss ich sagen, das ist wirklich gut geworden.
Also da hat Deutschland genau das, wie wir uns das gedacht haben in den Verhandlungen,
dass das sein soll, mal niedergeschrieben.
Es ist noch nicht so, dass man jetzt sagen kann, okay, da ist die technische
Spezifikation drinnen. Die kommt erst später von der EU-Kommission.
Das ist ganz spannend, weil in den nächsten sechs, sieben Monaten muss die Kommission das vorlegen.
Und Deutschland hat da natürlich mal was auf den Tisch gelegt,
was die Kommission nicht ignorieren kann.
Das freut mich jetzt mal nur so als Datenschützer, weil damit die Latte ein
bisschen höher gelegt wurde, als ich das aus vielen anderen Ländern kenne.
Da wird Datenschutz gerade bei digitalen Identitätssystemen bei Weitem nicht so wichtig genommen.
Es gibt auch noch Kritikpunkte, die wir an diesem Architekturvorschlag haben.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du Daten über dich weitergibst an eine Firma,
weil du jetzt eine Versicherung abschließt oder bei einem Hotelcheck-in,
da ist ja alles denkbar an privatwirtschaftlichen Use Cases.
Gibst du nicht nur deine Daten weiter auf einer vertrauenswürdigen Verbindung,
sondern du gibst auch die staatlich beglaubigten kryptografischen Echtheitszertifikate weiter.
Sprich, es ist dann auch für diese Firma, die deine Daten bekommt.
Kryptografisch nachweisbar, dass die von diesem Staat als echt und authentisch zertifiziert wurden.
Und das schafft ein paar neue Probleme, die wir so noch nicht hatten.
Erstens mal, du kannst damit parallele Infrastrukturen aufbauen und dadurch
natürlich auch abseits von diesem EIDAS-Regularium, wo es vielleicht klare Grenzen
gibt, was mit den Daten passieren kann und da kann auch eine Firma ausgeschlossen werden,
wenn ich die Daten mal habe, kann ich ja irgendwie mein Parallelsystem aufbauen
damit. Technisch wäre das dankbar.
Und das zweite ist natürlich, der Überwachungskapitalismus freut sich unheimlich,
wenn du nicht mehr irgendwelche so Webformulareingaben hast,
wo man vielleicht noch lügen kann oder tricksen kann oder Dinge weglassen kann.
Sondern wenn du halt wirklich weißt, diese Daten sind staatlich beglaubigt.
Das ist wirklich dieser Mensch, das ist seine Adresse, das ist seine Führerscheinklasse,
seine finanzielle Situation, Familiensituation, Name sowieso.
Also das wiegt schon sehr schwer und da gäbe es bessere technische Möglichkeiten,
diesen Austausch zu gestalten, ohne die Signaturen mitzuliefern.
Und deswegen, ja, da gibt es sicherlich noch Bewegungsspielraum so ein bisschen
und das ist jetzt mal nur in der Nutshell, wie wir dieses Datenschutz,
dieses Architekturkonzept sehen.
Aber jetzt komme ich zu dem eigentlichen Punkt dieses Themenblocks und zwar,
wie kommt man zu der Software?
Und da hat sich die Bundesregierung mit dieser, ich glaube die heißt so Agentur
für Sprung, Innovation, Sprint, sind sie auf die Idee gekommen,
wir machen da so ein mehrstufiges Verfahren, wo eingangs sechs Firmen oder Konsortien ausgewählt werden.
Ich glaube, das müssen gar nicht Firmen sein, aber es sind so sechs Anbieter,
die Software bauen wollen.
Die bewerben sich, da werden sechs ausgewählt, die kriegen mal einen Batzen
Geld, damit sie was bauen können.
Nach ein paar Monaten gibt es die zweite Stufe, wo dann glaube ich vier übrig
bleiben und wiederum eine zusätzliche Finanzierung gegeben wird,
um das Ganze weiterzuentwickeln.
Und zuletzt sollen zwei Anbieter übrig bleiben, die in der dritten Runde von
einer Jury ausgewählt werden, wiederum Geld bekommen, um die Dinge auch fertig zu entwickeln.
All das soll Open Source sein und sich an dieses Architekturkonzept halten.
Das ist schon mal spannend, weil eine komplette Open-Source-Implementierung
zu haben, ist sowieso die Voraussetzung dafür, dass man so einer Software vertrauen kann.
Aber das hilft natürlich auch allen anderen Ländern, wenn da schon ein Software-Stack
da ist, zu dem man sich zumindest verhalten kann.
Es ist nur Open Source, es ist keine freie Software, es stellen sich vielleicht
immer noch Lizenzfragen, aber trotzdem ist dieser Ansatz nicht schlecht und ja,
auch zum Kern der Sache zu kommen, diese Jury von zehn Leuten wird jetzt gerade
gesucht und unter anderem wurde auch ich gefragt, ob ich da nicht hineingehen will.
Und das wollte ich, ich habe mich da noch nicht letztlich entschieden,
ich wollte das mal auch mal hier offen einfach in der Sendung mit dir und auch
mit den Hörerinnen besprechen.
Für mich ganz entscheidende Punkte war, dass es die Möglichkeit einer dissenting opinion gibt,
also wenn man nicht mit dem Mehrheitsvotum der Jury einverstanden ist,
dann kann man auch Punkte anbringen, die in der Begründung, die für jede Firma
oder für jeden Einreicher dort, der eine Wallet bauen will, dann veröffentlicht werden.
Du kannst dich natürlich nicht zu denen äußern, die du ablehnst,
das wäre ein bisschen nachtreten,
aber trotzdem glaube ich, dass es sinnvoll ist, so dissenting opinions zu haben,
dass du einfach on the record geben kannst, was Bedenken sind und dass man halt
trotzdem auch vielleicht weiß,
es gibt wirklich Augenmerk auf Datenschutz bei der Auswahl jener Konsortien
oder Firmen, die hier versuchen, eben mit staatlichem Geld so eine Wallet zu bauen.
Es gibt auch eine Aufwandsentschädigung, das sind drei Termine,
wo es jeweils 1000 Euro gibt.
Das geht natürlich an Epicenter Works als den gemeinnützigen Verein,
wo ich das ganze tue im Rahmen meiner Anstellung.
Und ja, das ist so grob, wie ich die Sache sehe. Tim, was denkst du dir?
Also zunächst einmal diese Bundesagentur für Sprunginnovationen,
die kennt ja vielleicht nicht jeder.
Das ist ja eine relativ neue Geschichte, ein Laden, der vom Rafael Laguna de
la Vera mit diesem klangvollen Namen geführt wird und mit dem hatte ich zum
Beispiel auch schon mal das Vergnügen einen Podcast aufzunehmen,
nämlich im Rahmen von Forschergeist, Forschergeist 91,
wo wir uns mal darüber unterhalten haben.
Und der Modus operandi dieser Bundesagentur an sich ist ja schon mal sehr entstaubt.
Also das ist zwar, es leuchten ja immer gleich alle Warnglocken auf,
wenn irgendwo Bundes davor steht.
Aber wie beim Bundestagszusammenfasser kann es halt auch mal anders laufen.
Und mein Verständnis ist, dass da sehr flexibel gedacht wird.
Und wo es halt auch darum geht, schnell zu Lösungen zu kommen.
Und ich habe auch so den Eindruck, dass da ein gewisses Grundverständnis der
digitalen Realitäten vorliegt. Das vielleicht mal erstmal so von vornherein. Und naja, warum nicht?
Also ich meine, das klingt ja ganz sinnvoll. Man wünscht sich ja eigentlich
immer diese Einbindung.
Man hat vielleicht manchmal so ein bisschen Angst, wenn man dann irgendwie auch
wirklich eingebunden wird, dann wird man dann vielleicht nicht erhört und dann
ist das so ein bisschen Feigenblatt und so.
Das ist natürlich durchaus immer ein berechtigter Einwand so grundsätzlich oder
zumindest etwas, was man für sich selber mal prüfen sollte, ob das so ist.
Klingt für mich jetzt hier erstmal so nicht, sondern hier gibt es halt wirklich
auch den Wunsch so etwas Sensitives dann eben auf einer Open Source Basis entwickeln
zu lassen und das ist ja erstmal kein Fehler.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir nochmal kurz sagen sollten, was das denn genau wäre.
Also EIDAS ist ja quasi die europäische Richtlinie, die, ist das eine Richtlinie?
Oder ist das eine Verordnung?
Eine Verordnung, die halt klar sagt, wie so Identifikation sozusagen abzulaufen hat in Europa.
Und diese Wallet soll was genau leisten?
Also diese Wallet ist eine App auf unseren Smartphones nach den Plänen der EU-Kommission,
die es uns erlaubt, online und auch offline, also wenn wir uns in physischer
Nähe begegnen, uns auszuweisen.
Einerseits mit unserer staatlichen Identität, also wer bist du und auch andere
Eigenschaften und Datenfelder über dich eben weitergeben kannst an sowohl öffentliche
Stellen wie auch private.
Dieses System ist nach allen Richtungen hin offen.
Das können beliebige Daten sein von Universitätsabschlüssen,
deiner Meldeadresse, Familienstand,
Lenkerberechtigung bis hin zu Hotelzimmerschlüsseln oder Kundenkarten.
Und auch die andere Seite der Gleichung gegenüber wem du dich ausweist ist offen.
Das können beliebige staatliche Stellen sein, Bund, Land, Gemeinde,
ganz beliebig, aber auch beliebige Unternehmen.
Das Ganze ist ein europäisches System, soll also wirklich interoperabel sein.
Dass du dich dann eben auch in Schweden oder in Frankreich mit diesem System bewegen kannst.
Es erlaubt auch die Authentification. Du wirst auch explizit bei Facebook,
bei Google und bei anderen Big Tech Plattformen die Möglichkeit finden,
dich mit dieser Wallet einzumelden bei dem dortigen Dienst.
Diese Very Large Online Plattforms gemäß Digital Services Act,
also die Big Techs dieser Welt, werden nämlich verpflichtet, die Wallet anzubieten.
Was ich für eine ganz schlechte Idee halte, aber so sieht es das Gesetz vor.
Und der letzte Punkt, den man nicht übersehen darf, ist, dass mit dieser Wallet
auch rechtsgültig unterschrieben werden kann.
Also es wird auf einmal sehr wichtig, dass du wirklich die Kontrolle darüber
behältst und nicht irgendjemand, der mal kurz Zugriff auf dein Handy hat,
dann einen Vertrag für dich unterschreibt oder einen Kredit aufnimmt oder so Sachen.
Das ist so grob der Funktionsumfang dieser European Digital Identity Wallet.
Ja, also ich finde es auf jeden Fall wichtig, dass dieser Prozess begleitet wird.
Da ist sicherlich eine Chance drin, auch wenn ich so intuitiv mir vor allem
wünschen würde, dass man da sehr eng mit den Betriebssystemherstellern zusammenarbeitet,
um sozusagen nicht nochmal yet another standard zu machen,
sondern gleich sozusagen auch zu sehen, okay, wie kann man das möglichst auch
auf Betriebssystemebene integrieren, dass man jetzt nicht alles immer in einer
App liefern muss, weil gerade wenn es um so sensitive,
sicherheitssensitive Dinge geht, dann ist ja in diesen Betriebssystemen und
in den Devices selber schon eine ganze Menge Basissicherheit vorhanden,
an die man sich ja andocken kann.
Können sollte und dann mit dem biometrischen Verfahren und sonstigen Schutzmechanismen,
die das System ohnehin schon mitbringt, dass das damit dann auch gekoppelt wäre.
Das wäre so jetzt mein Take, aber ich möchte jetzt hier nicht in eine technische
Diskussion gehen, aber ich empfinde jetzt sagen wir mal dieses Engagement als
solches finde ich nicht falsch.
Zu diesem Sicherheitsaspekt, weil da stichst du gerade in ein Wespennest hinein,
darum wird nämlich gerade gestritten.
Wie viel kann ich aus dem Nähkästchen plaudern? Ich glaube, es ist nichts verkehrt,
wenn ich das mal irgendwie aufnehme.
Wir sind ja unter uns, Thomas.
Es ist so, dass es da ganz unterschiedliche Vorstellungen gibt zwischen den Mitgliedstaaten.
Manche Länder meinen, die Private Keys sind sowieso immer nur bei uns am Server
und dieser Wallet, die darf nicht mehr sein als ein Frontend,
aber alles, was wirklich kriptografische Signaturen betrifft, ist bei uns am Server,
weil nur wir sind vertrauenswürdig, hat natürlich massive Datenschutznachteile.
Weil wenn du das nicht sauber machst, ist es sehr leicht möglich,
auch an zentraler Stelle nachzuvollziehen, was die Leute denn so tun mit dieser
Wallet, die vielleicht bei jedem Einkauf, bei jedem ÖPNV-Trip und so weiter zur Anwendung kommt.
Dann gibt es das Modell, wo Österreich zum Beispiel auch dafür ist,
dass man sagt, wir haben doch die Secure Enclaves und die Chips auf diesem Telefon,
denen vertrauen wir doch.
Hier ist es so, dass durch den Digital Markets Act geregelt ist,
dass der Staat auch den Zugriff bekommen muss auf diese Chips.
Und dass jetzt Apple nicht hergehen kann und sagen, nee, unsere Infrastruktur
ist so super secure, ihr dürft da nicht irgendwie das skriptografische Schlüsselmaterial ablegen drauf.
Und da stellen sich auch einige technische Fragen, wo ich gespannt bin, wie man das lösen will.
Aber das ist so der zweite Ansatz.
Nutze das, was du gerade gesagt hast, die Sicherheit des Telefons.
Und der dritte Ansatz, der vor allem von Deutschland präferiert wird,
den ich auch für den sichersten halte, ist, sobald es ans Eingemachte geht,
also wirklich ans Unterschreiben oder an, man nennt das Level of Assurance High,
da muss der Personalausweis mit dem Chip ans Telefon gehalten werden.
Und nur dann kannst du diese Funktionen ausführen, weil das wirkliche Schlüsselmaterial,
das bleibt auf der Chipkarte des Personalausweises und geht nicht auf das Telefon.
Und gerade weil es zum Beispiel in Norwegen zig Fälle gibt, wo dieses Unterschreiben
für andere Leute zum echten Problem wurde, glaube ich, dass dieser Ansatz sogar
auch aus IT-Sicht übrigens der bessere wäre.
Aber darum wird gerade gestritten, was sich da am Ende als EU-Standard durchsetzen wird.
Ist noch absolut offen. Da wird gerade massiv gezogen, das IIDAS-Gesetz ist
noch nicht im Journal der EU veröffentlicht, im Amtsblatt.
Das wurde so ein bisschen lange hinausgezögert.
Ich glaube, weil da im Hintergrund noch bestritten wird, sobald das im Journal
veröffentlicht wird, was dem Vernehmen nach sehr bald der Fall sein soll,
läuft eine Uhr und dann gibt es nur noch sechs bis maximal zwölf Monate,
bis die Kommission diese technischen Standards festlegen muss.
Und dann wissen wir auch viel mehr, wie die Interoperabilität grenzüberschreitend funktionieren soll.
Ja, also von daher ist es sicherlich ganz sinnvoll, sich dort einzuklinken.
Ich habe so ein bisschen Angst, dass da halt wieder so Fummelsachen bei rauskommen,
wie wir das jetzt gerade mit dieser Ausweis-App gehabt haben.
Dann soll das dann im Web gehen und dann gibt es dann irgendwie keine zuverlässige,
sichere Verbindung zwischen der Webseite und dieser Karte.
Also ich verstehe eh nicht, warum es einem dann die Telefone auch so schwer
machen, kryptografisch diese Prozesse auch irgendwie mit Webseiten dann auch
in Verbindung zu bringen.
Und so ein Vorgang, wo halt auf der einen Seite mein Personalausweis zum Einsatz kommt,
aber eben auch eine sichere Brücke zu digitalen Gegenstellen geschlagen werden
muss, wenn man es in Anführungsstrichen richtig machen will,
da ist es halt unter Umständen dann auch erforderlich auf die Hersteller mal
zuzugehen und zu sagen, ihr müsst jetzt diese Schnittstellen aber auch anbieten,
damit wir nicht irgendwelche komischen Fummellösungen machen.
Wie wir das jetzt hier gesehen haben, da machen wir jetzt eine URL und dann
wird irgendwie die App aufgerufen und dann passt das schon irgendwie so.
Das ist halt so ein bisschen an der Stelle so ein bisschen wackelig.
Und dann wird die falsche Methode gewählt, weil bei der Entwicklung nicht richtig
drüber nachgedacht wurde, wie man das jetzt irgendwie gelöst bekommen würde
und dann schafft man sich da eben so eine.
Einsprungsstelle für Unsinn.
Und das ist schwierig und Ich denke, das muss auf breiter Front vorangebracht
werden, aber es muss vor allem darauf geachtet werden, dass es ordentlich gemacht wird.
Absolut. Wir können ja in den Kommentaren nochmal Feedback sammeln dazu.
Diese Frage ist, glaube ich, eine ganz spannende mal zu diskutieren.
Wir sind ansonsten immer sehr bedacht darauf, auch unsere Unabhängigkeit zu wahren.
Und zum Beispiel, wenn jetzt irgendjemand von uns Beratung haben will,
wir tun das nur unentgeltlich.
Wir könnten dafür kein Geld nehmen, weil dann wären wir befangen,
wenn im nächsten Moment dann ein Journalist kommt Und unsere Meinung haben will zu diesem Thema.
Das geht sich für die Rolle als NGO und Watchdog meiner Meinung nach nicht aus.
Und hier gibt es natürlich auch eine Verschwiegenheitsvereinbarung,
weil du in der Jury natürlich schon über Geld entscheidest.
Ich glaube, in Summe sind es grob drei Millionen, die da vergeben werden.
Und deswegen ist das was, das ich jetzt so noch nicht hatte und ich kann aber
gerade, weil das wirklich staatliche Infrastruktur ist,
wo so viel dranhängt, will ich, dass da Datenschutz ernst genommen wird und
das ist was, wo ich Ahnung habe und da hoffe ich auch,
dass im Hinblick auf so...
Eine Vergabe von Steuergeld, um eine wirkliche allgemeine Infrastruktur zu bauen,
wo ganz viele Teile der Gesellschaft ja dann auch davon abhängig sein werden,
da macht es einfach Sinn, am möglichst inklusiven Prozess zu wählen.
Und für mich ist ganz entscheidend, dass ich halt, wenn ich da reingehen sollte,
mich dann nicht mehr äußern kann zu dem Projekt als solches oder zu einzelnen
Dingen, wenigstens in Form der Dissenting-Opinion nochmal sagen kann,
okay, das war zwar die Entscheidung, aber es gab Chatham House anonymisiert
zumindest folgende Gegenpunkte bezüglich dem und dem.
Und ich hoffe aber auch, das ist ja immer die schöne Sache, wenn du als NGO
in so Juries bist, Du bist eigentlich die schwächste Partei,
weil du hast keine Lobby im Hintergrund.
Gleichzeitig bist du die, wenn du aufstehst und sagst, Leute,
das erfüllt den Zweck nicht mehr, dann haben alle ein Problem.
Also oft gibt es dann schon einen Konsens und ich hoffe, dass überhaupt auch
genügend Angebote reinkommen, wofür wir sagen, ich will was datenschutzfreundliches bauen.
Dann hat man vielleicht wirklich auch was für ganz Europa geschaffen,
weil am Ende des Tages geht Deutschland hier voran und das finde ich mutig und gut.
Da muss aber auch wirklich was dabei rausschauen, dass unseren europäischen Werten auch Genüge tun.
Ja, aber am Schluss bist du die Schuld dann, ist klar.
Ja, wie immer.
Gut, dann kommen wir gleich mal zu dem nächsten potenziellen Spaltpilz,
wo sich verschiedene Meinungen auftun, nämlich digitales Geld und das Recht
auf Bargeld ist natürlich da auch mit drin.
Voll, das ist ein Thema, das war schon mal bei Logbuch Netzpolitik 465 Thema
und da würde ich gerne anschließen und so ein bisschen ergänzen,
weil es ist da was passiert, gesetzgeberisch.
In der Sendung damals haben Linus und du ja auch diesen Souveränitätsgedanken
aufgebracht und da kann ich euch recht geben,
das war auch ein starker Motivator für jene Kräfte, die dieses Gesetz nach vorne gebracht haben.
Souveränität meint hier, wir haben jetzt gesehen, wie schnell man in Russland
digitale Bezahlsysteme abdrehen kann.
Wir haben irgendwie Donald Trump als Frontrunner bei der amerikanischen Präsidentschaftswahl.
Was würde denn in Europa passieren, wenn wir auf einmal keine digitalen Bezahlsysteme mehr hätten?
Weil, oh Wunder, kein Unternehmen in diesem Bereich ist wirklich europäisch.
Das sind alles amerikanische Dienstleister.
Also diese Idee der Sanktionen war ein treibender Faktor.
Also was das in dem Zusammenhang meint, ist halt sowas wie Frontend,
so Apple Pay, Google Pay, beziehungsweise vor allem natürlich dahinter die Kreditkartennetzwerke,
also die Visa- und Mastercard-Netze, die ja im Prinzip die Welt unter sich aufteilen.
Ganz genau. Und auch die Cryptocurrency-Assets, Blockchain-Bullshit-Sachen,
die da von Big Tech kamen.
Libra habt ihr damals erwähnt in der Sendung, den Vorstoß von Facebook,
von Meta, hier eine digitale Währung zu schaffen,
hat den Zentralbanken auf der ganzen Welt unheimlich viel Schrecken eingejagt,
weil Facebook kann schon nicht mit Daten umgehen.
Jetzt wollen wir ihnen nicht auch noch Geld in die Hand geben.
Also dieser Vorschlag eines digitalen Euros ist idealistisch und ideologisch
irgendwie verständlich.
Aber die Frage, die Linus auch gestellt hat, was bringt mir das denn als Konsumentin
oder Konsument, die ist weiterhin unklar.
Und das sagen auch einige der Konsumentenschutzorganisationen,
dass im jetzigen Vorschlag ist der Vorteil für Konsumentinnen nicht klar.
Auf einer hohen Ebene bin ich schon der Meinung, dass so etwas wie Bezahlung,
Geld ist schon was, das wir lieber demokratisch regulieren, als es jetzt irgendwie
einer Firma zu überantworten.
Und die EZBau sieht ja auch, dass immer weniger von dem Geld,
was ihres ist, noch unterwegs ist.
Weil eigentlich sind nur die Münzen und die Scheine, die wir in Händen halten
können, wirkliches Zentralbankgeld.
Geld auf deinem Bankkonto und Geld auf der Visa-Karte oder in Apple Pay,
das sind Schuldverschreibungen mit der Bank, mit Visa oder mit Apple.
Und dadurch ist es eben nicht mehr Geld, das wirklich in den Händen von der
Zentralbank ist und da ist es auch so ein bisschen für sie ein Schritt,
den sie setzen, weiter relevant zu bleiben.
Also um es gleich mal korrekt zu machen, also Apple Pay ist natürlich keine
Schuldverschreibung, das ist ja ein reiner Zugangsdienst,
die Dienstleistung sozusagen der Vermittlung der Zahlung und auch wenn du jetzt
Kreditkarten über Mastercard und Visa abwickelst,
Man kennt die zwar als Kreditkartenanbieter,
aber genau genommen sind es ja erstmal Kreditkarten-Netzwerkabwicklungsanbieter.
Ob die Kreditkarte, die dann da abgewickelt wird, eine von diesen Unternehmen
ist, das ist nochmal eine andere Sache.
Die Kreditkarten werden schon in der Regel von deutschen Banken ausgegeben und
das Geld, was die deutschen Banken oder überhaupt die europäischen Banken halten,
das ist ja letztlich schon auch Geld der Zentralbank, weil da leiden sie sich das ja aus.
Du hast schon recht, ich glaube es ist für die EZB trotzdem so dieser Gedanke,
das sind alles amerikanische Firmen, die könnten das abdrehen und was passiert da?
Ja, es geht um die Infrastrukturen und sozusagen, also ich denke die Grundidee
beim digitalen Euro ist,
dass man sozusagen auch noch einen anderen Weg hat, so eine unmittelbare Bewegung
von Euro-Geld, die nicht sozusagen auf andere Infrastrukturen angewiesen ist,
die sozusagen eine eigenständige Infrastruktur darstellt.
Sodass man eben, wie man eben das mit Bargeld macht,
auch den Euro direkt digital bewegen kann, ohne das über private Infrastrukturen
zu machen, die im Zweifelsfall abgeschnitten werden können.
Also dass man sozusagen einen direkten Weg hat, in dem man auch eine direkte
Darstellung des Geldes, was die EZB eben ausgibt, nämlich den Euro, hat.
Und die gibt es halt derzeit so nicht.
Und damit es das geben kann, benötigen wir halt Standards, die es derzeit nicht gibt.
Und das ist natürlich nicht Blockchain oder irgendein Voodoo,
weil das ist ja eher der Versuch an der EZB Geld vorbei zu schmuggeln für Personal
Gain und Kriminalität und Spenden an Nordkorea, da ist das ja sehr populär.
Sondern eben einen eigenen Standard aufzumachen oder natürlich im Idealfall
auch einen international gültigen Standard für Geld sozusagen,
der eben den Anforderungen entspricht.
Absolut. Und wie du gerade gesagt hast, es sind da viele technische Fragen noch nicht geklärt.
Ihr habt euch ja damals, glaube ich, im Juli 23 zu dem Thema geäußert.
Und seit Juni 23 haben wir die dazugehörigen Gesetze, die von der Kommission vorgestellt wurden.
Und diese Gesetze sind aber, eh so wie wir das aus der EIDAS kennen,
großteils Überschriften und grobe rechtliche Konzepte und Konstrukte,
wo aber die Dinger, die einen interessieren, um da vielleicht auch eine Aussage
zum Datenschutz zu machen, komplett fehlen.
Es gibt doch so gut wie keine Rechte, die ich als Person habe,
wenn ich jetzt diese Währung verwende.
Was darf eingesehen werden, was nicht.
Und da fehlt unheimlich viel an Safeguards, was aus unserer Sicht wichtig wäre.
Und diese Gesetze, ich verwende hier den Plural, weil es noch ein zweites gibt,
das Recht auf Bargeld, auf das komme ich gleich,
aber beim digitalen Euro ist es so, dass da zwar die DSGVO korrekt wiedergegeben wird,
auch mit den Bestimmungen, wer was verarbeitet und was für Daten von wem und
zu welchem Zweck, aber halt eben auf einer technischen Ebene.
Wie wird hier Privacy by Design garantiert?
Was habe ich denn vielleicht noch für Zusicherungen, dass zum Beispiel zumindest
für Kleinstbeträge gewisse Informationen nicht anfallen über eine tägliche Transaktion,
wie ich sie vielleicht durchführe?
Es gibt nämlich bei diesem digitalen Euro das Versprechen der EU-Kommission,
dass diese Währung und dieses Zahlungsmittel datenschutzfreundlicher sein soll
als alle anderen digitalen Bezahlsysteme.
Das ist nicht schwierig, weil die sind alle so schlecht, dass da besser sein ist easy.
Aber dann sagen sie auch und der digitale Euro, vor allem der offline digitale
Euro soll besser sein als Bargeld, was Datenschutz betrifft oder zumindest genauso gut wie Bargeld.
Das ist ein Versprechen, an dem messe ich sie die ganze Zeit,
weil da sind sie meilenweit davon entfernt.
Und du hast doch bei vielen Sachen dann so erst ausgelagert in zum Beispiel
Delegated Acts, also Verordnungen, die später kommen und dann einseitig von
der Kommission erlassen werden.
Regeln zur Geldwäscheprävention und Terrorfinanzierung, die natürlich die klassischen
Feinde vom Datenschutz sind bei so Bezahlsystemen.
Und das ist auch ein superschwieriges Problem, weil du hast doch diese ganze
Frage des Double Spendings und du willst da ja Kohärenz sicherstellen in so einem Währungssystem.
Es gibt bei dem digitalen Euro zwei Ausprägungen, einen Online- und einen Offline-Digital Euro.
Beim Online-Digital Euro muss zumindest eine Partei der Käufer oder Verkäufer, Payer oder PI,
online sein, weil da alles immer in der Infrastruktur der EZB abgebildet wird,
die sogenannte Settlement-Infrastructure.
Kann man sich so vorstellen wie eine einfache Datenbank.
Keine Blockchain, alles nur bei der EZB, aber da hast du jede Transaktion drin.
Und der Offline Digital Euro, der soll wirklich auch dann funktionieren,
wenn beide Parteien offline sind.
Und da stellt sich dann schon so die Frage, ich habe Geld, das auf Nullen und
Einsen basiert und kopiert werden kann.
Wie schaffe ich es, dass das nicht einfach wie alles Digitale kopiert wird und
dann zwei, drei, viermal Millionenfach ausgegeben wird?
Und da ist eine einzige Antwort, die sie gefunden haben.
Ja, wir haben in diesen Smartphones doch diese Sicherheitschips,
diese Secure Enclaves eingeführt.
Wir vertrauen denen einfach mal komplett und wir wetten die Stabilität der Eurozone
darauf, dass da schon nichts passieren wird.
What could possibly be wrong? Ja, okay.
Ausgeschrieben. Fun Fact, Amazon ist einer der Player, der sich hier reingeschmuggelt
hat und auch jetzt das Währungssystem bauen will.
Und um den Offline Digital Euro abzusichern, haben sie gerade einen Tender vor
zwei Monaten rausgegeben mit sage und schreibe 1,2 Milliarden Euro,
um da technische Standards und Absicherungskonzepte und aber auch den Betrieb
dieser Währung dann abzubilden.
Das ist Ja, für ein Gesetz, was noch nicht beschlossen ist, wohlgemerkt,
das Gesetz, Sie wollten unbedingt, dass das jetzt noch vor der Wahl durchgeht,
das haben Sie nicht geschafft.
Es gibt massive Bedenken, unter anderem vom Datenschutz von uns,
aber auch von den Banken, die da große, große Sorge haben, hey,
damit geht ja Geld uns flöten, wenn das nicht mehr Euros bei unserem Konto sind,
die wir verborgen können an andere Kunden, sondern digitale Euro,
die ja direkte Schuldverschreibung mit der EZB sind.
Auch wenn wir da das Kundenverhältnis halten und die Vertragsbeziehungen eingehen,
dann haben wir da die große Angst, dass uns das Geld abhanden kommt und deswegen
hat man auch eine Grenze eingezogen, dass keiner mehr als 3.000 Euro verdient.
Digitale Euro sozusagen zu einem Zeitpunkt halten kann. Also der Digital Euro
sollte kein Store of Value sein.
Also so wie das Geld unter dem Kopfkissen der natürliche Feind der Bank ist,
soll auch der Digitale Euro kein Feind der Banken sein, indem man einfach eine
Grenze einzieht von 3000 Euro. Euro, mehr digitale Euro darfst du nicht halten.
Das ist natürlich auch wieder überhaupt nicht im Sinne der Bevölkerung,
aber es ist halt so ein Geschenk, das man den Banken macht.
Also ich habe jetzt nicht viel Kenntnis darüber, wie da der aktuelle Debattenstand
ist in diesem Umfeld, weil ich mich da einfach nicht drin bewege.
Aber grundsätzlich würde ich ja sagen, erstens, wenn man etwas schaffen will,
was unmittelbar auch in der Bedienung und in der Akzeptanz mit dem,
was wir derzeit so mit Kreditkartensystemen haben, mithalten soll,
dann muss man im Prinzip auch genau auf diesem Level mitspielen.
Und das wäre halt zumindest erstmal, dass sozusagen die EZB Infrastrukturen
aufbaut, um im Prinzip eine Alternative zu sein zu so etwas wie Girocard,
so etwas wie Mastercard und Visa im Sinne von Payment-Netzwerke.
Dass man also sozusagen selber auch als Payment-Netzwerk auftritt,
weil so funktioniert das halt jetzt sozusagen.
Du willst mit deiner Uhr im Supermarkt zahlen, dann muss es ja irgendeine Clearance
geben. Es muss ja irgendjemand sagen.
Diese Transaktion darf stattfinden, für diese Transaktion ist das Geld da und
ich stelle jetzt auch sicher, dass diese Transaktion hier bei dem einen dazugeht
und bei dem anderen weggeht und das passt schon so.
Das ist ja im Prinzip was so ein Bezahlnetzwerk einem sicherstellen will.
Also Security, Einhaltung von Gesetzen im Sinne von Geldwäsche und Transaktionen
und wo es hingehen darf und wo nicht oder was für Transaktionslimits sind oder
was auch immer in der ganzen Rechtsgeschichte mit drin ist.
Und wenn du dann eben sagen willst, wir wollen aber von Mastercard und Visa
von diesen Netzwerken unabhängig sein, naja dann musst du halt dein eigenes Netzwerk haben.
Und wenn man das eben auf Basis des Euros und der EZB macht,
dann muss man halt irgendwie ein Trusted Netzwerk haben.
Im Prinzip haben wir sowas ja auch schon, das ist halt das SEPA-System,
das macht schon einen Großteil davon, das ist ja digital,
hängt bloß eben noch an diesen anderen Netzen dran, weil da eben die Händler dran hängen,
weil die Bezahl-Terminals eben Verträge haben mit irgendwelchen Dienstleistern
und das merkt man ja dann auch mal wieder, wenn irgendwas abgelehnt wird und
dann kannst du mit Master bezahlen, aber mit Visa nicht und so weiter.
Im Prinzip müsste man hier sehr langfristig vorgehen und sagen,
okay, wir machen jetzt hier sozusagen den Euro auch direkt bezahlbar und direkt darstellbar.
Den Offline-Euro, ehrlich gesagt, da habe ich so meine Zweifel,
ob das überhaupt gelingen kann.
Also ich glaube, das ist schwierig, weil das einfach ein generelles informatisches
Problem ist, was ja zum Beispiel diese ganze Blockchain-Geschichte überhaupt
erst losgetriggert hat, weil dieses Double-Spending ist halt einfach ein Problem. Leben.
Klar, da kann es irgendwie Lösungen geben, ich frage mich halt nur, ob die so wichtig sind.
Weil das Bargeld, was in geringen Mengen vorgehalten werden kann,
anonym und bei den Leuten sein soll.
Das funktioniert auch nicht digital. Also da gibt es auf meiner Meinung nach
nicht so den unmittelbaren Druck, das digital machen zu müssen.
Das ist natürlich so ein bisschen das Problem, dass jetzt du Läden hast,
die eben sagen, wir wollen aber jetzt hier nur noch digital bezahlt werden,
weil Bargeld ist uns irgendwie zu teuer und zu aufwendig und das wird geklaut
und das muss man zählen und rollen und bei der Bank abgeben,
wenn man das dann auch auf dem Konto haben will und dann muss man dann noch
Gebühren dafür bezahlen und so weiter.
Hast du dich übrigens auch schon mal gefragt, warum manche Restaurants nur Bargeld annehmen?
Weil es da Gebühren gibt für die Händler.
Ja, also dieses Gebührenargument ist ja sozusagen, naja, ich will keine Gebühren
an Mastercard zahlen und an
die Banken sozusagen, also an die Kreditkarten möchte ich nichts zahlen.
Obwohl das ist aber gedeckelt, meistens, also zumindest bei Konsumentengeschäften
ist es gedeckelt. Das ist aber irgendwie ein relativ überschaubarer Betrag mittlerweile.
Dabei ist Bargeldhandling eigentlich viel schwieriger, weil du das musst du
halt irgendwie sichern und das darfst du dir nicht klauen lassen.
Das kostet auch Geld, wenn du das in größeren Mengen an der Bank einzahlst.
Also das hat meistens eher was mit Steuervermeidung zu tun und nicht,
weil man irgendwie nicht am digitalen Transaktionssystem teilnehmen möchte oder
da höhere Kosten hätte, meine ich.
Also unabhängig davon, ich sage einfach nur, ich glaube nicht an den digitalen
Offline-Euro, bis ich da irgendwie Standards gesehen habe, die sagen,
nee, passt schon, das funktioniert auch und das kriegen wir irgendwie auch hin,
weil ich halte das einfach für schwer zu lösen, aber eben auch nicht unbedingt notwendig.
Die eigentliche Frage ist halt eher, will man überhaupt eine Welt haben, wo man auf...
Die Akzeptanz von normalem Bargeld verzichten darf.
Also darf das Unternehmen sozusagen erlaubt werden, nicht Bargeld anzunehmen.
Und das wäre wahrscheinlich eher so der Hebel, bis man eben wirklich eine digitale
Lösung hat, die funktioniert.
Zum Recht auf Bargeld komme ich gleich noch, aber ich würde gerne einhaken bei
dem, was du gerade gesagt hast.
Und diesen Punkt, wie kommt der digitale Eurer überhaupt zu den Leuten und zu
den Händlern, ist ein ganz wichtiger.
Wichtiger und da muss man halt leider auch, also war ich in Runden,
wo dann irgendwie Leute von der EZB, ich argumentiere so mit,
hey, aber wir müssen doch schauen, dass das Vertrauen der Bevölkerung irgendwie
da ist und die so We are the legal tender.
It's a legal obligation to accept. We don't need to care about trust.
Also, ein bisschen verklausuliert, aber es war schon so, wir können das halt
ins Gesetz reinschreiben und genau das haben sie hier auch gemacht.
Also, jeder Händler in der Eurozone Der Geld annimmt und heute irgendeine Form
von digitaler Bezahlmethode anbietet, muss dann auch den digitalen Euro verwenden.
Und die Gebühren sind reguliert. Da gibt es zwei Zahlen.
Das eine ist, was ist denn sonst üblich für digitale Bezahlsysteme an Gebühren
für den Händler und wie viel kostet es uns, den digitalen Euro in die Welt zu
bringen? Und welche der beiden Zahlen niedriger ist, ist dann die festgesetzte
Gebühr, die alle zahlen müssen.
Und dadurch wirst du das halt einfach wirklich in der Fläche en masse sehen, wenn es soweit kommt.
Zu dieser Frage des Datenschutzes nochmal, wir haben halt im Moment,
kann man das beurteilen?
Es ist einem Gesetz schon einigermaßen klar, wie es ungefähr technisch funktionieren soll.
Beim Online Digital Euro hast du einfach eine zentrale Infrastruktur,
da ist jede Transaktion drinnen gespeichert.
Und das komplette Datenschutzkonzept baut darauf auf, dass die EZB uns verspricht,
nicht hinzuschauen, wer jetzt was gezahlt hat.
Also die Daten sind pseudonymisiert, sie können aber aus Gründen wie Fraud Detection,
Anti-Money Laundering, Terror Financing und anderen halt einfach trotzdem hineinschauen
und reidentifizieren. Das heißt Vollüberwachung.
Und beim Offline Digital Euro ist es halt so, ja das ist in dem Telefon in irgendwelchen
Chips und denen vertrauen wir und alle X Transaktionen wird ein Stand an Offline
Digital Euros wieder gesynkt und jetzt kommen sie auch drauf,
dass sie da Haftungsregeln brauchen,
wenn Nordkorea vielleicht mal auf die Idee kommt, ein bisschen zu spielen mit diesem System.
Es gibt da technische Dokumente, die sind um einiges konkreter als die Gesetze.
All das wird in relativ opäken Runden im Moment verhandelt, wo wir unser Bestes
tun, irgendwie eine Verbesserung hinzubekommen. Das gesamte Thema hat nicht
die Aufmerksamkeit, die es verdient.
Und es ist leider auch so, dass da eine Karotte dran hängt.
Also dieser digitale Euro, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es dafür überhaupt eine
Mehrheit gibt. Aber deswegen gibt es ein zweites Gesetz in diesem Paket und
das ist das Recht auf Bargeld.
Und da haben alle Leute eigentlich Lust drauf, zumindest in Zentraleuropa.
Dieses Recht auf Bargeldgesetz würde nämlich wirklich bedeuten,
dass überall in der gesamten Eurozone, auch am Land, die Verfügbarkeit von Bargeld
gewährleistet sein muss vom Staat.
Das heißt auch, dass Banken dann zum Beispiel wieder Geldautomaten aufstellen
müssen oder mehr Schalter zur Verfügung stellen müssen.
Also die Versorgung mit Bargeld muss gesichert sein. Da gibt es auch Monitoring und so weiter.
Und es gibt auch eine Annahmeverpflichtung. Also wie wir das heute kennen, no cash, only card.
Schilder gehören damit der Vergangenheit an, wenn dieses Gesetz so kommt.
Das wäre wirklich eine super Sache, weil der schleichende Verlust des Bargelds
ist aus vielen Gründen schlecht. Es gibt Leute, die haben kein Bankkonto.
Bargeld ist der datenschutzfreundlichste Weg zu bezahlen. Und es ist auch für
die Financial Literacy, also für den Umgang mit Geld, glaube ich,
ganz hilfreich, dass du einen Bezug dazu hast und dass nicht nur irgendwelche
Zahlen auf deinem Display sind.
Und auch natürlich dann im Falle von Naturkatastrophen zum Beispiel,
wenn der Strom weg ist oder das Netz weg ist,
glaube ich nicht, dass der digitale Euro der Weg ist, wie sich Menschen noch
im Wirtschaftsleben austauschen können, sondern das wird einfach Bargeld sein. Nein.
Ja, wir verlinken noch auf die ganzen Policy-Analysen, die Epicenter Works dazu
gemacht hat und diese Arbeit wird eben nach der Wahl, der EU-Wahl jetzt im Juni weitergehen.
Es ist auch ganz spannend, weil wir einen super großen Überhang von deutschen
Abgeordneten bei dem Gesetz haben, aber davon hören fast alle auf.
Also der Berichterstatter Stefan Berger von der CDU hat einen sehr unwahrscheinlichen Listenplatz.
Die Schattenberichterstatterin der Grünen, Henrike Hahn, tritt nicht nochmal an.
Ein Gunnar Beck von der AfD ist auch Deutscher, aber von dem weiß ich nicht.
Mit der AfD-Wahlisten beschäftige ich mich nicht.
Ich habe kein Schmerzengeld. Und auch im Rat, also bei den EU-Mitgliedstaaten,
man konnte sich nicht einigen.
Also das Thema wird auf jeden Fall erst in Zukunft dann nochmal final entschieden.
Deswegen gibt es die Chance, sich näher damit zu beschäftigen und das ist eine Einladung.
Wir verlinken auch das Procedure-File, das ist so ein Cheat-Hack im EU-Gesetzgebungsprozess,
da kann man nämlich immer nachschauen, wo so ein Gesetz gerade steht und wer es zuständig ist.
Also wenn sich da Leute einbringen wollen, es ist gerade die Zeit dafür da.
Gut. So, jetzt haben wir eigentlich das meiste durch.
Kleinigkeiten haben wir noch ein paar, oder?
Ja.
Chatkontrolle, wir müssen das Wort sagen. Keiner kann es mehr hören. Wie geht es?
So wie Beetlejuice, Chatkontrolle, Chatkontrolle, Chatkontrolle.
In unserer Chronistenpflicht sei gesagt, dass es wieder mal einen offenen Brief
gab von 50 NGOs und 26 Expertinnen, der wiederum massive Grundrechtsbedenken äußert.
Wir haben in der vorletzten Folge darüber gesprochen, dass da die belgische
Ratspräsidentschaft im Moment ein bisschen freidreht und fast irgendwie jeden
dritten Tag einen neuen Gesetzesvorschlag vorlegt. Wir müssen uns einigen jetzt sofort.
Darauf nimmt dieser Brief Bezug, den eben ganz viele NGOs an die Kommission
geschickt haben und da ist dann auch das dazugehörige Leak natürlich gekommen.
Wie könnte es anders sein von André Meisler, der auf Netzpolitik.org da Protokolle
veröffentlicht hat von den Ratsverhandlungen und auch auf Mastodon einen Tut
abgesetzt hat mit einem wunderschönen Slide-Bild.
Man könnte es fast nicht besser ausdrücken, wie die belgische Ratspräsidentschaft
hier an dieser Stelle, wo man so eine schöne Grün- bis Rot-Tabelle hat und High-Risk
ist Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung.
Und da müssen wir am meisten überwachen und das geht überhaupt nicht.
Also es wird einfach immer deutlicher und das bildet sich auch im Rat ab.
Es gibt die, die verstanden haben, dass Verschlüsselung nicht böse ist und dass
Menschenrechte auch im Internet gelten und dass man da nicht alles überwachen kann.
Und da gibt es die andere Fraktion, die sagt, aber die Kinder und Verschlüsselung
ist böse und wir müssen alles scannen, weil vielleicht kommen wir da ja auf
irgendwelche Person of Interest.
Ja, und genau dieser Konflikt spielt sich hier gerade ab und ist schön irgendwie darstellbar.
Deswegen verlinken wir auf diese Dinge und halten die Daumen,
dass es nicht zu einer Einigung kommt, bevor die EU-Wahl passiert und dass wir
hoffentlich dieses Thema irgendwann beendigen und beerden können.
Hoffentlich dann, wenn die EU-Kommission anders aufgestellt ist und Innenkommissarin
Ilvia Johannsen hoffentlich ihren Job verliert.
Die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt. Gut.
Aber sie stirbt, wie Arne Semstroth sagt.
Das wollte ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Gut.
Alright, dann haben wir nur noch einen Teil, nämlich ein paar,
nein, genau, einen Termin.
Der Netzpolitische Abend Wien mit allen Spitzenkandidatinnen zur EU-Wahl wird stattfinden am 22.
Mai 2024 ab 18 Uhr in Wien bei der Digi-Society im 1.
Bezirk. Es haben schon zugesagt die Europaabgeordneten und Spitzenkandidatinnen von links an,
Kommunisten, Grüne, Liberale und Konservative, die Sozialdemokraten und die
Rechtsextremen, die FPÖ, die fehlt noch.
Und ich habe den Spaß, dass ich das moderieren darf und den Europaabgeordneten
halt so ein paar Fragen stelle zu netzpolitischen Themen.
Und es wird einen Livestream geben, eine Recording, das wird auf freien Radios ausgestrahlt.
Aber wer schnell ist, kann sich jetzt auch noch anmelden, um physisch dabei zu sein. 22. Mai in Wien.
Und ihr habt noch Kommunisten, ja?
Ja, die kommen gerade wieder. Die waren, ja, draußen, aber jetzt kommen sie wieder.
Die haben in Graz, ist jetzt Stalingrad, weil es kommunistisch regiert ist. Was?
Ernsthaft? Oh Mann. Okay. Und was ist die Digital Society?
Eine NGO in Wien, die auch Netzpolitik macht und ganz viele Events und Bildungsbereich
und so und die haben halt irgendwie ein schönes Office im ersten Bezirk und,
da muss man sich ja irgendwo treffen, wo es was hergibt Ja.
Ist doch schön, alles klar Gut, haben wir das auch mal genannt,
Fein mehr Termine haben wir nicht im Angebot und mehr Themen haben wir auch
nicht im Angebot das heißt wir sind schon voll im Epilog,
Thomas.
Der Epilog. Ja, also ich hoffe, dass deine Ausreise genauso leicht funktioniert
wie alles andere bisher dort.
Für die Einreise. Ja, naja, da habe ich überhaupt gar keine Bedenken.
Meine nächste Haltestelle ist dann übrigens die Türkei.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, wie das so wird.
Da bin ich neidisch. Bitte gehen die Hagia Sophia und Scheitersalz.
Ich habe es noch nie nach Istanbul geschafft, aber ich will da unbedingt mal hin.
Genauso ging es mir nämlich auch und diesen Malus, den wetze ich jetzt mal aus
und bin gespannt, was ich da so alles entdecken werde.
Aber ich kann sagen, es war jetzt schon eine sehr gute Idee,
diese Studienreise, wie ich es nenne, hier gemacht zu haben,
weil es einfach mal Einblicke liefert und andere Perspektiven liefert.
Gerade der arabische Raum ist ja sehr vielfältig in seiner Meinungsbildung. Das ist mal sozusagen.
Und da kriegt man dann einfach auch einen anderen Blick auf die Heimat.
Wenn man sich immer nur so in seinem eigenen Wölkchen dreht,
dann kann man da vielleicht viel kennen,
aber ob man dann auch immer so die Perspektive mitbekommt, die der Rest der
Welt so hat auf die Dinge, das sei mal dahingestellt.
Das bist du ja sicherlich aus deinen internationalen Reisen auch so bestätigen können, oder?
Absolut und ich glaube, dass du auch gerade in einer sehr spannenden Region
bist und da gibt es einfach eine Denkschule und einen Kontext und kulturelle Hintergründe,
die wir so leicht und gerne übersehen in Europa.
Und da jetzt genau hinzuschauen ist, glaube ich, auch für die Podcasts,
die du machst, ganz wichtig, dass das ein bisschen mehr 360 Grad hat und inspiriert ist von dort.
Aber das hast du mir voraus. Das Einzige, was ich dir mitgeben kann,
ist Mitbringsel aus diesen Ländern, meistens Zuckergebäck und Tee und Datteln.
Das sind so die besten Sachen.
Die ich bisher bekommen habe. Super hier. Steht vollkommen außer Frage.
Na gut, alles klar. Dann würde ich sagen, winken wir mal hier schön in die Runde.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und dann hören wir uns nächste Woche wieder. Tschüss und bis bald.
Ciao, ciao.